A wise man once said a movie is only
good as its ending and I know it's true
because I actually found that in a
fortune cookie but boy oh boy is the
ending to Netflix's latest Thriller the
Stray is gonna make you wish you were
abandoned by your parents I've abandoned
my child the story follows Neve which
derives from the Latin word Nevis
meaning snow an app name considering
this is a woman who literally wants to
be white around the year 2003 she
decides to leave her poverty-stricken
family including her two children to
start a new life in an affluent white
neighborhood so if you want to follow a
completely unlikable character for about
an hour and a half this is a great story
for you although Neve later tells us she
was in an abusive relationship hence why
she left she makes no effort to contact
her kids so not only did she leave them
but left them with an abusive father she
could also be completely lying as we'll
find out throughout the story Neve lies
and keeps Secrets more than my
ex-girlfriend neeve's shunning of her
children parallels the shunning of her
black identity she wears a wig to hide
her hair gloves to hide her skin and
practices a posh accent marries a white
man doesn't like her daughter's hair in
cornrows and has her son Sebastian puts
it I think she's white never says
anything about her past anything black
off limit this is a really interesting
concept a black woman wanting to become
white but the Strays never delves Beyond
The Superficial what about nav
psychology makes her want to be this way
was there some sort of past trauma which
caused her to have this outlook on life
unfortunately the only reason we get for
her wanting to join white Suburbia is
this I want more
is it wrong to want more it just makes
her greedy she's abandoning her children
for her own personal gain and at least
for me makes her character not worth
rooting for the juxtaposition between
black and white is brought into her
perspective with the arrival of Neve's
two abandoned children some 16 years
later when Neve is on the screen we get
excerpts of classical music while with
her children a mix of rap and Southern
hymns her children Carl and Dion crash
her fundraising Gala which ironically is
for impoverished children in Africa this
turns Neve's world upside down and
unbeknownst to her family she offers to
pay her kids off so they'll go away so
if we didn't hate her enough we can add
paying off the kids you abandoned to
your list there's also this hilarious
scene where she tries to justify
abandoning them by essentially saying
fathers do it all the time why not her I
think what I had to do
what fathers do all the time now the
series actually did one thing I thought
was pretty cool the whole movie is split
into different sections where you see
the story played out from different
perspectives the first is nevs then Carl
and Dion's followed by Cheryl who was
Neve's real name before she changed it
and finally family reunion but these
different perspectives are somewhat
convoluted I kept wondering why Carl and
Dion didn't knock on Neve's door and
approach her about the abandonment
instead they devised this elaborate
scheme involving getting jobs close to
her family befriending her kids and
sending toys from their childhood to her
is this meant to scare her are they here
for revenge or for answers it's never
really explained and the whole thing
just becomes a confusing mess not to
mention Sebastian dev's son befriends
Carl The New School Janitor who gives
him cigarettes and Drugs in what world
are you going off into the woods all
alone with this school's janitor but
things really break down in the film's
Final Act Carl and Dion break into
Neve's house and hold the family hostage
not only is this ridiculous but it also
goes against the very thing the film is
fighting against racial stereotypes
earlier in the movie we get this scene
between the white suburbanites where
they discuss the topic of white flight
in which white people flee urban areas
because they're quote unquote uncultured
yet Carl and Dion are framed as
uncultured smoking weed destroying the
hotel room giving alcohol and cigarettes
to miners breaking and entering
head-butting threatening people with a
machete forcing a kidnap family to play
a twisted game of Scrabble the list goes
on are we supposed to be rooting for
them are we supposed to be sympathetic
to their plight when they commit
violence against people like Ian who
himself was a victim of Neve's lies
there is no one in this movie worth
rooting for which brings me to the
ending so Carl and Dion break into the
house and hold Neve's family hostage
forcing them to order Chinese food and
play Scrabble which for me sounds like a
pretty decent night not only do we not
know how they plan to get away with this
but we're never quite sure what their
intention is are they here to kill them
get money scare them I'm still clueless
the front door is also open and any one
of them could just run out at any time
and scream for help Carl even lets Neva
answer the door to pick up the Chinese
food and she doesn't even ask the
delivery guy for help not to mention how
did they order ubereats from the
landline when all their phones were
destroyed for some reason Carl takes Ian
and Neve's husband into the weight room
and has him do bench presses where it's
implied he's killed by the weight no
real reason why he makes him do this
especially considering Ian himself is a
victim of Neve's lies and deceit what
does Carl have against Ian now what does
Neve do as all this is going on she just
leaves that's the end of the movie she
just [__] leaves she abandons her new
children just like she did her old ones
at the beginning now I know what the
writer is doing here they probably
thought in their mind that this ending
is profound but what it really leaves us
is a movie without an ending it's also a
movie that doesn't really know what it's
saying about complex issues like
abandonment race or motherhood like if
you were to ask me me what I thought the
theme of the movie is I don't know I
guess I'd say don't abandon your
children but that's a pretty damn weak
theme especially the way it's executed
in this film so the Strays kind of
sucked but what did you think should we
abandon this movie I want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below thanks
for watching Everybody for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember I've abandoned my child
[Music]
thank you